nous sommes maintenant direct avec
didier quitté médecins infectiologues et
épidémiologistes suisse bonjour et merci
de prendre le temps de répondre à nos
questions 1 sur rt france arte france
vous présidez depuis le 25 juin dernier
la mission coville de l'elysée est ce
que c'est un avantage d'être suisse quel
regard portez-vous sur la gestion de la
crise sanitaire en france
et quelle est votre mission aujourd'hui
auprès d'élise est alors écoutez est ce
que c'est un avantage d'être suisse je
ne sais pas c'est en tout cas peut-être
lié à au fait d'être neutre d'être mais
avant tout je crois d'être scientifique
est d'abord un regard calme posé
certainement experts sur la gestion de
la crise au niveau de plusieurs pays
dans le monde
la mission que m'a confié emmanuel
macron que qu'a confié emmanuel macron à
au groupe d'experts que j'ai l'honneur
de présider est une mission qui ont font
demande d'accéder à la façon dont la
france a géré la crise en matière
sanitaire en matière économique en
matière sociale et sociétale et de
comparer la réaction de la france à
celle d'autres pays à l'international et
c'est probablement une des raisons pour
laquelle on m'a désigné pour la
présidence de cette mission compte tenu
de mon expérience auprès de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
de différents systèmes de santé dans le
monde voilà et le travail a
effectivement commencé et pour l'instant
je ne peux pas vous en dire beaucoup
plus alors que l'ex l'expert que vous
êtes va sans doute pouvoir vous éclairer
deuxième jour consécutif que le nombre
de contaminations quotidien on dépasse
les 3000 nouveaux cas en france voilà
plusieurs semaines que les chiffres
repartent à la hausse et pourtant le
nombre d'os mutantes d'hospitalisation
n'augmente pas au même rythme alors
c'est évidemment une bonne nouvelle mais
comment analysez vous cette situation
alors écoutez le fait que le nombre
d'hospitalisations n'augmente pas au
même rythme que le nombre de détections
des nouveaux cas est tout à tout à fait
le reflet de ce qui est attendu
aujourd'hui
puisqu'au fond
avec une politique très large de
dépistage des nouveaux cas on dépiste
évidemment les situations dans
lesquelles le virus peut être propager
de manière facilitée
c'est à dire avant tout dans les
populations relativement jeunes voire
jeunes a très jeune et ces populations
là sont moins affectés par le virus et
donc ne vont pas être infectées de
manière sévère et de manière a nécessité
une hospitalisation est donc pour
l'instant il n'y a pas d'hopital iations
bien entendu si malheureusement ces
personnes là on venait à ne pas être
repéré par la santé publique et en
venait à être en contact avec des
personnes vulnérables dans ce cas là ces
personnes vulnérables pourraient être
malheureusement victimes d'infections
qui serait beaucoup plus significative
voire sévère et dans ce cas là nous
aurions les hospitalisations
parce qu'on le rappelle en permis à
l'est les nouvelles contaminations il ya
principalement des jeunes contaminés
parfois sans le savoir
que répondez-vous aux médecins qui
propose aujourd'hui en dépistage
obligatoire pour les plus jeunes et ce
après deux semaines de la rentrée
alors écoutez le dépistage obligatoire
en lui même n'a fini finalement qu'assez
peu de valeur puisque au fond si vous
êtes dépister aujourd'hui et que vous
êtes négative
cela ne veut pas dire que vous ne serez
pas finalement positive demain ou après
demain ou la semaine prochaine
donc il ya plusieurs façons de voir la
chose je crois que le premier message
est que un maximum de personnes qui ont
les moindres symptômes doivent avoir
accès aux tests diagnostiques qu'on
appelle parfois dépistage mais en fait
lorsqu'on allait moindre symptôme
il s'agit d'un test diagnostique pour
confirmer que vous ayez ou non la
maladie qu vide ou que vous soyez
peut-être même si vous êtes minimale
moins symptomatiques infectés par le cos
vide à ce moment là vous allez devoir
être isolés et les personnes qui ont été
en contact avec vous selon les règles de
santé publique devant être mis en
quarantaine
alors dépistage systématique il convient
finalement de répondre aux appels de
santé publique est ce que lorsque la
santé publique va demander un dépistage
systématique dans une zone où dans une
région où autour d'une école où autour
d'une situation particulière alors à ce
moment là oui il s'agira que chacun
finalement se prête à ce dépistage
systématique qui sort après pour des
raisons de santé publique
le vert au hasard au niveau 2 de toute
la population que ce soit en france en
suisse ou ailleurs
évidemment ce serait utilisé beaucoup de
tests de dépistage pour une rentabilité
et une évidence épidémiologique qui ne
serait pas souhaitable
puisqu'au fond les capacités des
laboratoires à dépister un nombre
maximal de deux personnes demeure quand
même non illimité je dirais nous
arrivons à une période où de nombreux
français vont rentrer de vacances
comment est ce que vous envisagez est la
reprise est ce qu'une deuxième vague de
l'épidémie vous semble inévitable alors
écoutez pour l'instant tout d'abord un
maximum de français ont pris des
vacances et c'est c'est bien cette
importance d'importants de d'avoir
repris cette énergie donc nous avons
nous allons tous avoir besoin à la
reprise c'est certain
certains reviennent de zones pour
lesquelles on a demandé la france a été
très clair à ce propos la queue des
dépistages soient réalisés au départ du
pays dans lesquels les personnes ont
pris des vacances ou au retour de
vacances et je crois que il faut se
prêter à cette stratégie c'est
extrêmement important
et puis encore une fois au risque de me
répéter le plus important sera de
respecter les mesures barrières qui sont
avant tout la distance sociale et
l'hygiène des mains et dans certaines
circonstances le port du masque avec une
hygiène des mains avant et après le port
du masque
je me plais à rappeler et puis
évidemment un test immédiat au cas on a
le moindre doute les moindre symptôme ou
éventuellement la notion que nous avons
été en contact avec des personnes
récemment documenté comme étant positive
c'est extrêmement important et il faut
que ces tests soient pratiqués avant mai
évidemment d'aller au travail si vous
avez des symptômes il ne faut pas aller
au travail et vous poser des question de
savoir si vous allez devoir vous faire
tester il faut d'abord aller dans un
centre de test et puis ensuite peut-être
employés sont appelés son employeur en
disant je me suis fait tester
aujourd'hui j'attends le résultat qui me
parviendra dans les 24 48 parfois 70
deux heures avant de savoir si je peux
revenir au travail je crois que c'est
une attitude qu'on demande à chacun et
chacune
il s'agit d'un respect du civisme de
chacun de manière à ce que tous ensemble
nous puissions lutter haute cette
situation qui il faut bien le dire est
est tout à fait inhabituelle et j'en
conviens alors le masque est en train de
devenir l'accessoire incontournable et
pourtant on a vu ces images comment est
ce que vous répondez qu'est ce que vous
répondez aux protestataires anti masque
alors écoutez les protestataires anti
masque je dois dire que nous devons
reconnaître qu'au fond ils manquent
avant tout de civisme le masque n'est
pas prescrit juste pour le plaisir il
n'est pas prescrit pour ennuyer les uns
ou les autres
il est prescrit parce que il est
important de bien réaliser que nous
sommes tous si je puis dire dans le même
bateau dans cette lutte contre la
transmission de ce virus
alors il est vrai que dans certaines
situations le mas qui n'est pas utile et
il est vrai que chacun doit bien
comprendre que ce masque est utile à
partir du moment où la distance qu'on
appelle parfois distance physique
distanciation physique parfois
distanciation social qui est peut-être
un terme qui n'est pas toujours apprécié
lorsque cette distance visite ne peut
pas être respecté entre les personnes à
ce moment-là ce port de masque est
absolument recommandé alors on peut pas
imaginer le nombre absolu de situation
ou parfois ce masque est finalement
porter pour une utilité douteuse mais
dans la mesure des possibilités alors
que ce masque est recommandée il
convient de respecter les
recommandations parce qu'au fond
le sont simplement que la participation
de l'individu du citoyen à la lutte
contre cette épidémie
aucun d'entre nous n'a envie que
finalement nous retournions à une
situation de confinement
comme on l'a connu et pour ça chacun
doit faire un petit effort
si ce petit effort consiste à devoir
porter un masque
à l'occasion il faut évidemment il y
adhérer alors un tout dernier mot parce
que malheureusement le temps nous manque
au sujet du virus et ce coin connais
mieux aujourd'hui est ce que vous direz
que la charge virale a évolué et de
quelle manière
depuis les premières contaminations
écoutez le virus on le connaît on
connaît bien entendu un peu mieux
on sait que ce virus se propage
extrêmement facilement mais on sait
aussi que les mesures barrières sont
totalement efficace et ça a été démontré
à stopper la propagation du virus donc
aujourd'hui ce virus on peut continuer à
apprendre des choses sur ce virus mais
rien ne nous fait peur par rapport à ce
virus
s'ils tentaient que nous puissions
respecter les mesures barrières et je
crois que c'est là le message le plus
important
merci beaucoup d'avoir été en direct
avec nous sur rt france didier pittet
médecins infectiologues et
épidémiologistes je rappelle que vous
présidez la mission oco ville de
l'elysée